there are now multiple investigations
underway as the Attorney General bar is
working hard to hold our government
bureaucracy accountable to fix this mess
that were created by some those that
would rig an investigation those that
tried to rig with Russian lies a
presidential election those that tried
to bludgeon and unseat a duly elected
president and the same cannot be said
for House Democrats they clearly are
more interested in a political circus
designed to smear the president all in
advance of the 2020 election there you
have House Judiciary Chairman Jerry
Nadler is now set to call John Dean of
Watergate Fame to testify in the Muller
report John Dean the star in witness and
Richard Nixon's Watergate scandal that
was 47 years ago he has absolutely
nothing zero to offer as it relates to
the Muller report or frankly any of the
issues that are at hand here nothing he
has no expertise on Russian election
hacking but Dean well he now works for
fake news CNN as a professional Trump
hater 24/7 hate rage psychosis so now
Jerry Nadler figures oh nobody more
perfect let's roll him out for yet
another Trump round of Trump bashing
even though he has no relevance to the
case and by the way if you're like most
Americans and you don't watch fake news
CNN or conspiracy TV MSNBC here's a
small sample of the great insight the
great knowledge the great objective
analysis of Jerry Nadler star witness of
what he will bring to Capitol Hill and
the circus that he's throwing over there
take a look Trump is showing true Nick
Sounion style
Trump is Nixon on steroids and stilts if
I had to channel a little of Richard
Nixon I think he'd tell this president
he's going too far this is the sort of
stuff of a Banana Republic this is what
an autocrat does frightening lead
dictatorial he's thinking like Putin
would think so why would Jerry Nadler
promote and obviously angry washed up
far left extreme left to CNN hack to
perform in front of his
Serkis Intel Chairman Adam Schiff well
he's busy continuing to lie through his
teeth as per usual and today the
Cowardly shift called the Attorney
General bar the second most dangerous
man in the country really take a look
and so we find ourselves I think for the
first time with an attorney general who
really is the president's defense lawyer
and spokesperson and who's quite good at
it and has the veneer of respectability
to camouflage what he's doing he is not
the the sophist that Giuliani is he's
much more dangerous and and I think he's
the second most dangerous man in the
country for that reason most dangerous
place in the country is being between
the Cowardly Schiff and either a
microphone or a camera because he's
obsessed with seeing himself and hearing
himself now it's this kind of baseless
vitriol it's nothing new because for
years the Cowardly ship has been
breathlessly promoting lie after lie
trump russia conspiracy theories over
and over again he's lied more than any
other single member of congress which
says a lot about him now we have invited
him for a full hour on this TV show I've
offered him three hours complete on my
radio program 616 stations so he could
defend his rest
reckless rhetoric that's four hours of
air times with me and I have a dossier
on everything he's ever said but like
all these other lying Democrats he
refuses to come on but the ship is not
only a coward he's a liar and he knows
he's a liar so instead of defending
himself he's just gonna double down on
his absurd lies that get more absurd
every day now maybe he'll even invite
fellow conspiracy theorists Rachel
Maddow to the hill two biggest liars in
the country together in one place at
last
now if CNN's John Dean can testify and
he has nothing to offer I guess anything
at this point is possible of course Matt
al could use the publicity because her
ratings as well as CNN ratings have
taken quite a dive since their lies and
conspiracy theories for two-plus years
have been exposed now that the mayor
can people no longer trust NBC's chief
conspiracy theorist by the way Tom
Brokaw are you proud of this
take a look we're about to find out if
the new president of our country is
going to do what Russia wants
once he's commander-in-chief of the US
military we haven't ever had to reckon
with the possibility that somebody has
ascended to the presidency of the United
States to serve the interests of another
country rather than our own what's the
corrective to that how do you remedy
that these are no longer hypothetical
questions this is where we are the
presidency is effectively a Russian op
it is like negative 50 degrees in the
Dakotas right now what would happen if
Russia killed the power in Fargo today
okay anyway sadly Maddow's delusion is
not uncommon in the so-called mainstream
media in other words the 99% of the
media that spent two years lying again
and again to the American people
smearing lying besmirched and conspiracy
theories fake news you name it they
dominate coverage on the three networks
Washington Post New York Times CNN MSNBC
and any other basic outlet out there now
of course they're merely doing the
Democratic Party's bidding as they work
in unison and they are only but an
extension of all things Democratic
Socialist and that's why the media is
ramped up their impeach finished area
after Muller's nine-minute public
diatribe disaster last week which
resulted in a complete retraction and a
complete clarification hours later
because those nine and a half minutes
contradicted everything he had been
saying up till that point in the end as
I've been saying Muller is done this
whole Muller investigation is over it's
finished confirmed by the Attorney
General the president is guilty of zero
crimes there was no collusion no
conspiracy with Russia and there was
none zero obstruction of justice but the
media they can't help themselves
after two years of lying perhaps they've
even convinced themselves that their
lies and conspiracy theories are
they're still begging for impeachment
for what reason they can't offer one
take a look
mounting pressure growing calls to start
impeachment after Robert Muller breaks
his two-year silence if the House
leadership doesn't start hearings now I
believe it's hard to see them ever doing
it in the months ahead
again now or never we seem to be moving
toward a place where impeachment may be
inevitable the dam really seems to be
breaking wide open what he was really
saying is Congress has a job to do it
was almost a Jeopardy question the way
Robert Muller put it yesterday
there is a process other than the
criminal justice system to charge a
sitting president what's the answer the
answer is impeachment so you got the
media mob Democrats deep state elites
all want the same thing get rid of
Donald Trump and they think their
problems go away they want to remove a
duly elected president of the United
States based on a hoax that they impart
created and perpetrated on the American
people now they think they know better
than us we the American people smelly
Walmart people irredeemable deplorable
z' people that cling to our God guns
Bibles religion you proved them wrong we
hold them accountable
we fight for justice because the future
of this country is at stake and that is
not hyperbole